frankreich ringt um seine innere
sicherheit gewalttätige demonstrationen
massenproteste und islamistische
anschläge heizen einen politischen
zweikampf an
marine le pen von der extremen rechten
wäre laut umfragen wahrscheinliche
herausforderungen emanuel makros bei der
nächsten wahl
dabei hat sie bei der letzten wahl gegen
ihn verloren die suche nach einer
erklärung für den le pens
abgeordnetenbüro corona die andere krise
der französischen politik immer wieder
hat le pen makro attackiert sie haben
wiederholt die gesundheitspolitik der
regierung kritisiert aber derzeit sinken
die infektionszahlen widerlegt dass
nicht ihre kritik ja die zahlen sinken
aber sie sinken überall in europa
wahrscheinlich ist es eine frage des
zyklus des virus sicher ist dass es
nicht mit der ausgangssperre und der
sperrstunde zu erklären ist die kurve
und die regierungspolitik soll wirklich
gar keinen anteil daran haben
bei der zweiten welle
nein ich denke nicht wir haben sehr
harte maßnahmen ergriffen die ganze
sektoren der wirtschaft in gefahr
bringen
einzelhändler handwerker freiberufler
das hat man gemacht ohne dass es
medizinische gründe dafür gab
erfolge der regierungspolitik bestreiten
wut von einzelhändlern anheizen le pen
setzt auf emotionen fakten sollen dabei
möglichst wenig stören
das gilt auch beim thema impfungen was
sagt le pen dazu dass sie in deutschland
menschen mit migrationshintergrund an
den impfstoff entwickelt haben
der wohl auch in frankreich verwendet
werden wird rasch klar sie können immer
mit solchen beispielen kommen ich halte
dagegen die dutzende islamistischer
terroristen
die 230 menschen in unserem land getötet
haben und die auch kinder waren als sie
kamen aber sie sind groß geworden und
haben dabei immer mehr delikte begangen
alle wege führen zum islamismus jeder
anschlag ist wasser auf ihre mühlen
als der lehrer samuel partie von einem
islamisten umgebracht wird eilt lücken
an die schule mehr agitation als
anteilnahme
[Musik]
ich gedenke dieses lehrers der
umgebracht wurde unter entsetzlichen
umständen durch einen
fundamentalistischen islamisten para
fundamentalistisch schlimm ist auch nach
dem anschlag in einer kirche in nizza
ist lücken schnell mit radikalen
forderungen präsent seit jahren führt
man gegen uns krieg wir brauchen ein
kriegsrecht dagegen das sage ich erneut
ein spezielles recht für diesen kampf
terrorismus ist die waffe der
islamistischen ideologie jeder anschlag
jede schweigeminute setzen die regierung
unter druck um die konkurrenz ganz
rechts zu neutralisieren greift sie zu
ähnlichen worten nicht um solche erfasst
wir sind im krieg gegen einen feind im
inneren und von außen wir sind nicht im
krieg mit einer religion sondern mit
einer ideologie der islamistischen
ideologie auch le pens forderung nach
stärkeren grenzen und mehr abschottung
tauchen bei der regierung wieder auf
wir haben entschieden wegen der
wachsenden bedrohung und im rahmen
unserer terrorbekämpfung die
grenzkontrollen im schengen raum
deutlich zu verstärken
wir haben beschlossen die zahl der
kräfte an den grenzen zu verdoppeln
doch makros strategie gegen rechts birgt
risiken
wenn eine bürgerliche partei versucht
rechtsextreme parteien zu kopieren bei
themen und wortwahl um ihnen stimmen
abzunehmen
dann ist das überall in der europäischen
union seit den 60er jahren gescheitert
wähler bevorzugen das original gegenüber
der kopie markus regierung will sich mit
law and order profilieren auch um von
rechts weniger angreifbar zu sein
mit einem neuen sicherheitsgesetz nach
massenprotesten die pressefreiheit werde
damit untergraben knickt die regierung
ein
frankreich im krisenmodus jede
gewaltsame demonstration spielte le pen
in die hände
viele franzosen werden sich heute trotz
allem bewusst dass wir nicht nur die
richtige diagnose gestellt haben sondern
auch am besten die krankheit unseres
landes heilen können
das mag wunschvorstellung sein doch auch
rechtsextremismus experten warnen davor
le pens partei vorschnell abzuschreiben
bei kommunalwahlen hat sich gezeigt dass
kandidaten die im zweiten wahlgang gegen
den front national antraten bisher immer
davon ausging dass sie in jedem fall
gewinnen aber wenn sie ein weniger
attraktives angebot gemacht haben dann
hat am ende le pens partei gewonnen
wer sich darauf verlässt dass es eine
natürliche obergrenze phillip ens partei
gibt verliert am ende wenn die
präsidentschaftswahl einige tage oder
einige wochen nach einem weiteren
terroranschlag stattfindet der ähnlich
dramatisch ist wie der mord an samuel
partie dann ist nicht abzusehen was
daraus entstehen kann
präsident makro vertraut darauf dass
eine mehrheit der franzosen in bei einem
zweikampf mit le pen am ende doch
unterstützt eine strategie mit risiken
marine le pen wartet derweil in aller
ruhe ab